eine nacht im grandhotel cosmopolis ich
als normaler hotelgast werde hier mit
asylsuchenden und künstlern unter einem
dach schlaf
wie wird sich das anfühlen wie
funktioniert das zusammenleben in diesem
hotel
sie nennen sich hoteliers aber
eigentlich sind sie künstler stefan
denner ist einer der mitbegründer und
stolz auf die gästezimmer ziemlich
aufwendig behandelt worden und wie man
sieht hier in einem stück geht durch ein
mann hat die betten
so fuhr seite an fous seite was ich auch
eine wahnsinns idee finden es steckt
viel liebe und kreativität in diesen
zwölf hotelzimmern alles unikate von
künstlern gestaltet
zimmer sind alle auf spendenbasis das
heißt wenn man eine nacht hier
verbringen können gibt es einen gewissen
mindestsatz den kann man erfragen und
wir freuen uns aber über mehr geben kann
dass der da noch gibt direkt neben dem
gäste truck die wohnungen der
asylsuchenden die für die hotelgäste
nicht zugänglich sind
das ehemalige altersheimes zur bühne
eines sozialen experiments geworden
vielfalt wohnen nennen es die
aktivistinnen künstler und freiwilligen
mitarbeiter und vielfältig ist das leben
hier tatsächlich vom backhaus bis zum
deutschunterricht findet hier alles
statt
natürlich mache keinen unterschied ob
ich weitermache oder ein foto machen
oder mit jemand koche und zieht kommen
das ganze haus zusammen die kinder der
asylsuchenden
die großen arbeiten in der küche mit ein
gemeinschaftswerk auch am tisch heute
steht afghanischer linseneintopf auf dem
menü der austausch mit den asylsuchenden
hat bei den künstlern einiges ausgelöst
wenn man mit leuten im haus lebt dann
kann ich mir als künstler schon
überlegen ok mach ich jetzt noch eine
soundinstallation oder stecke ich wollte
meine kreative arbeit vielleicht in der
kampagne um der person zu helfen
die frage nach der verantwortung der
kunst glaube ich innerhalb von so einem
projekt ist schon eine große sieht ein
bisschen nach beschäftigungstherapie
haus aber das gemeinsam erschaffen von
kunstwerken hilft tatsächlich als
handwerker hat yunus schon in
tschetschenien gearbeitet
vor zwei jahren ist er mit seiner
familie hierher nach augsburg gekommen
im grupotel cosmopolis fühle ich mich
wie im kreis meiner engsten verwandten
es ist ein ort der ruhe in den letzten
32 jahren in meinem heimatland aber ich
mich nie so sicher gefühlt wie hier
ich glaube das kommt auch daher dass die
gemeinschaft hier schon eine art
schutzraum bietet ein schutzraum ist ja
nicht nur eine verortung sich nur
wirklich eine räumlichkeit das ist ja
auch ein gefühl das vermittelt wird und
ich glaube sicherer man sich fühlt desto
leichter fallen
kritiker nannten das kartell cosmopolis
auch schon ein luxus asylheim doch das
projekt scheint tatsächlich zu
funktionieren
glaubt man den betreibern finde hier
viel weniger gewalt statt als in anderen
asylheim und auch sprachlich sei die
integration einfacher und doch leben die
asylsuchenden hier wirklich so
harmonisch zusammen beobachten und hören
auch in den gesprächen mit den leuten
die der tatsächlich ohne welche
schwierigkeiten es gibt und es gibt hier
rassismus es gibt hier chauvinismus
es gibt alle probleme die so kannst du
auch hast hier ist nicht im paradies
hier ist nicht so dass man denkt okay
man macht jetzt eine idee und dem
konzept und man nimmt ein paar künstler
und man noch ein paar freundlichen
nachbarn und dann setzt man ein paar
asylbewerber in das bild rein und schon
ist es irgendwie eine glückliche story
mit happy end so ist es nicht es kommen
gute ergebnisse raus und wir sind sehr
zufrieden glaube ich mit den erfahrungen
die wir machen aber der weg dorthin
dauert und der weg dorthin ist nicht
ohne
holpe steinen
das kurhotel cosmopolis setzt ein
kleines feines zeichen ein zeichen der
hoffnung für ein besseres zusammenleben